you are so cute check out your nails
your rings your outfit your hair so cute
Jeff's on the show I'm getting tips have
you ever do you know what is that he is
apparently he's a daddy yes I did I am
so old apparently in denial yeah you
know it's like a Zed day is that it yeah
and that's I mean that is yeah I agree
with it
I just didn't know what it was at first
yeah so you were on broad city and it
was a comedy duo
so how was that breaking off you've been
doing that show for since 2009 I think
it's a part of your life with the and
that's a long time to work with someone
then all of a sudden you're like on your
own it's crazy to look back I'm 32 and
like ten years is pretty much a third of
my life and my partner Abbi Jacobson and
I give it up for a day
yeah IV and I started the web series in
2009 and it's just been this climb and
climb to the show and but we had five
seasons fifty episodes on Comedy Central
and we created it together and show
around it and produced it and we're so
proud of the show and it's my favorite
show and it's kind of cool because it
didn't end because of anyone else it
ended because y'all wanted it to end
which is really Clarkson haunted I'm
just saying that's rare like usually
people are like no more and you're yeah
yeah and also like women don't usually
get to be like enough you know yeah and
all the way yeah so um I do but this was
I think the first time Abby and I both
we're like you know what this is a good
time to end it and it keeps that power
in the show that we already have created
yeah so what were you like as a kid were
you were you both at talkative cuz
you're both even though you might not be
a static commune you're very comedic
actor like so we're y'all and you're
very friendly or y'all both like this as
kid where'd you grow up Pittsburgh
Pittsburgh Oh got you Long Island
bullets for Long Island really for
the whole area but we always just
talkative or were you introverts when
you were kids I was I was talking to my
brother and I would mix my brother
Elliot is also comedian and we make
sketch videos for hours and hours and
hours we I've always been a comedy nerd
and that's it were you always this
talkative you knew everyone right off
the bat no no I was very I was sort of I
needed to be a good boy in school I made
good grades and there was kind of I was
you know huh you said a good little boy
we it was in a strict house well they
were kind of straight there was some
kind of you know serious demand that we
be well behaved in one area now they're
in school certainly so I was kind of
constrained so I it was a kind of an
outlet when I found myself I had to find
my voice by-and-by as I'm still doing
but I I remember well I had I was I had
a talent for drawing and painting and my
dad would take us to the special art
class me every week and waiting outside
the Carnegie Mellon Museum the Carnegie
Museum Wow what what he what he hadn't
shown up yet and I would do this thing
that I can't believe I did I was like 11
or 12 I would see people and then
pretend to know them to go oh my gosh
look who it is
yeah 14 or 11 or 12 or some like you
think it was to make you feel more
comfortable that you were alone in that
moment I don't know
yeah not was me practice I was the seeds
of something something creative and yeah
I just wonder where everybody kind of
comes from in their background but tell
us about your upcoming comedy tour my
tour in March is a stand-up tour and I'm
going to 9 cities around the country and
I'm really excited about getting out the
word to vote this year it's 2020 it's a
big year and I also just want to say I
like I'm just starting to understand
what the census is and why it's
important but that's also important this
year so my stand-up shows we're gonna
have we're partnering with head count to
register voters and then I'm staying an
extra night in each city to throw a
voter empowerment dance party with my
political organization generator you
know voter you love like vote for what
you believe in but vote that's important
you know and especially I always get
upset when I have female friends that
don't cuz I'm like do you know how hard
other women had to fight for us to have
the chance to be able to do it right
it's some yeah with like whoever you
vote for I don't care but for you want
to vote for but like vote it's the least
we can do and it's so it's everything
and growing up in a small town and
leaving and going to like other parts of
the world you really realize how lucky
we are so I love that you're doing like
a dance party making it a cool vibe yeah
the UM the whole tour is called horny
for the poles I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this